tu suces qu'ont dit les enfants se vient
vous voir quand ça besoin d'un truc
papa j'ai besoin de ton aide je prends
mon manteau 30 ans dans le futur nous
sommes en guerre
il faut que vous veniez battre va bien
ouais je vais à la guerre arrêtez de
parler mais écoutez je suis jean à 97%
sur l'échelle de la nervosité on va se
marrer
vous et votre unité est maintenant en
rien de ce qu'on fait ici n'a
d'importance
c'est là que tu te trompes
ensemble on fera en sorte que cette
guerre n'arrive j'ai eu l'opportunité
d'offrir au monde une seconde chance
la seconde chance arrive pas vraiment
souvent
[Applaudissements]
je dois filer à la caserne tu retournes
à l'hôpital je suis de garde ce soir
on se voit plus tard
suis toujours inquiète de devoir partir
un
incendie survenu à la centrale nucléaire
la d'urgence radiative vient d'être
déclaré
[Musique]
si l'on n'intervient pas tout de suite
au coeur du réacteur ce n'est pas la
population locale aux mêmes kiev que
l'on risque de contaminer c'est toute
l'europe
on est au bord du gouffre la population
n'a pas besoin de savoir on risquerait
de provoquer l'hystérie générale
concentrez-vous sur le recteur de nos
charge de la politique
les volontaires seront récompensés vous
ne comprenez pas cette mission suicide
les sommes que vous allez envoyer n'ont
jamais été formés à ça c'est peur de
mourir alex je te promets qu'on va s'en
sortir
[Musique]
avec moi
les spirou
[Musique]
j'ai bien on sortira de cet enfer
en fait on ne fait plus peur on fait
dans le rire maintenant désolé si vous
nomme tous les deux à la tête du service
fourie connu le riz et notre amour il va
falloir embaucher une bonne armée de
monstres marrante s'il vous plaît que
tyler scott terreur attitré quoi terrain
voulez dire que vous n'engagez plus de
terreur adieu les terreurs bonjour les
blagueurs c'est une blague affecté à la
mi
temps
le petit nouveau est là taylor tasse pas
les meilleures pâtes à l'université on a
suivi d'un courant sont prêts mais
quelques courses et même pas parlé
excusez moi c'est quoi exactement la mif
tu sais quoi la mif tu as laissé partir
la monstre intervention fort steam
quand une machine a besoin d'être
entretenues ou l'entretien à toi
on n'en parle plus jamais personne n'a
rien vu bon personne n'a rien je venais
ici à titre provisoire unique outil doit
être ré aucun des mister ne quittera son
poste je vais apprendre de terreur à
devenir drôle je suis pas sûr que
c'était une excellente idée
n de livrer le casque et le badge de la
jeune recrue bienvenue chez monstres et
compagnie
[Musique]
leo au fus par 14 ans s'ils vont il ya
du tabac dont
trois jeunes cherchent bien qu'aucun nom
n'aura pas le temps me lancer bah si
moisés pipi ça fait deux heures ont fait
la queue pour toi alors maintenant tu 3
sur youtube en battant
[Musique]
vous rendez pas compte en fait on a
transféré nos esprits dans le corps de
quelqu'un d'autre
on hésite la plus grande découverte de
l'immunité les mon anniversaire
c'est pas le moment pour l'anniversaire
vous inquiétez pas on rentre à la maison
ce soir et surtout et ont l'air normal
et si ce pas ça vous partez ouais c'est
dommage ça pour chalon
on
va pourquoi c'est pas juste c'est mon
anniversaire mais [ __ ] fait circuler
mais comment tu me parles
bouazizi non arrête avec ton saisie
maintenant et du fidèle au
sérieux c'est dans le corps de papa
maintenant
je me tiens à votre insu sa gamme s'il
avait oui c'est ça j'en suis vieille et
moche et barbu mélange de calme
fait chier votre truc mais
je te rappelle je t'explique premier
[Musique]
[ __ ] mais dégage là tu vois pas une
gêne
à
des ars hier effrontée à et venant vous
sauver
[Musique]
écoute tu vas bity sy
manigances
dit d'ailleurs t'as jamais envie d'être
adoptée par une famille et habiter
ailleurs non je suis très bien ici fait
tout ce que je veux
[Musique]
fait de très jolis sourires à cette
petite c'est à yagg ans on va prendre
seul s'y
[Musique]
prend bien soin de toi
moi je m'appelle payer la ja car je suis
une sorcière si tu fais correctement ton
travail ne sera pas maltraités qu'elle
sait pas que les sorcières fées des lave
linge
ça y est maintenant je veux bien que
même la magie morales et réveille toi
vas me cueillir des orties et des
hellébores
prophète sachent que dans cette maison
il y a une règle incontournable
rae qui ne veut être dérangé sans aucun
prétexte
[Musique]
ils nous exploitent salle sorcières on
est drôlement malheureux en question
[Musique]
attend l'équipe comment se protéger
contre toute sorte de magie
m
qui me
[Applaudissements]
en juin sur salto
gerry byrne steen sera notre agent de
liaison avec la nsa voulait bien faire
le point de la situation en deux mots
histoire de maître par finans
mais sur une affaire qui implique la
banque d'angleterre on n'a pas besoin de
l'agent de liaison américain
vous êtes dans mon département et je
suis mon équipe
je voudrais chronométré à quelle vitesse
nos collègues sont capables d'enlever
leurs vêtements ou on vous et tendus
quoique on a beaucoup à apprendre l'un
de l'autre notamment vous n'est ce pas
bon ben je suis comme ça moi
intelligence saison 2 inédite dès
maintenant sur salto point fr
aujourd'hui tu vas manger sain et
équilibré
après avoir déposé la gosse tu haïras
ton cours de danse classique je passerai
une bonne journée j'ai ri au café
équilibré toi tu ce burger signature 3
grande frite un milkshake au chocolat
après avoir dépoussiéré gosse
j'irai à mon cours de danse classique
permet pas serait une bonne journée le
professeur robin va se faire virer on
leur a besoin de pognon - j'étais un peu
importe qui tu as tu penses que ça va
mal se passer non tu a confié ta vie et
ce blaireau
saddam désolé
vous n'êtes pas ton cela et voilà bravo
elle voit que t'es qu'une pauvre fille
paumée
je n'étais pas senti aussi bien depuis
très longtemps
tu veux je prends des cours d'aérobic et
triste ça pourrait vous plaire des
premiers cours tu sens déjà changement
ton corps reprendre contrôle combien de
temps on va pouvoir vivre sur nos
économies on doit tous participé et
quand il dit on ça veut dire toi t'as
jamais porté engagé un autre point c'est
qu'une foire tango je veux pouvoir
j'espère oxydé à droite on est désolé
pour voter à gauche
ça arriverait par à suivre fondre dans
le décor ce qu'on pense que vous
ressentez je pourrais venir chez vous
vous donner un cours privé il ya une
petite chance pour que ce soit pas une
ligne au côté fric
[Musique]
walcott
c'est pas de quoi je suis capable
vous allez construire quelque chose
quelque chose de solide et qui est
seulement avant c'est quoi ce bordel et
personne ne venant les bras
je n'estime pas
[Musique]
on va leur en mettre plein la vue
champions
[Musique]
oh
approche
jusqu'à taba
non je francs
ni aux patients
[Musique]
t'as fait quoi et on n'osait y
jettent mbarak al adha renault bled pour
sa retraite
il est déjà parlé j'ai pas envie du gsm
r je vois pas d'issue cette fois
je m'appelle qu'en ce moment tusa règne
toujours là dans ta caisse à me supplier
dans les plans de fontès pas tu vois pas
que ces morts là moi je suis tout seul
béziers bah rien qui me retient ici
pour effet des prix
je sais rien pu construire ensemble
c'est fini ça jamal a bien là je te
porte violence au travail au triage
[Musique]
et ce succès
je
suis resté
l'internement
moitié du championnat
mais cap
[Musique]
6 non non non
tu toi oui
[Musique]
mon
hahaha
voilà
[Musique]